good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
here on the breakfast show on Sky News
UK bracing for a Christmas of chaos
after a summer of disruption from rail
to male nurses teachers and even
University lecturers speaking to union
bosses and also joined by the leveling
up secretary that's Michael Gove of
course plus this guy who speaks to
Manchester United's co-owner found out
what he had to say about plans to sell
the club it is Thursday a 24th of
November
Christmas Chaos a winter wave of
industrial action as workers across all
sectors of the economy walk out
scores shot in Scotland as teachers
strike in the first national stoppage in
almost four decades while the UK's
biggest ever University strike hits
campuses
I'm on the picket line as more than a
hundred thousand Royal Mail workers go
ahead with industrial action over some
of the busiest online shopping days of
the year
the Manchester United co-owner avram
Blazer tells Sky News in his first
interview since the club was put up for
sale why he's doing it
the board went through a process and
it's decided it's going to look at
different strategic Alternatives and
that's what we're doing
bullet and Marx an NHS Mental Health
Trust in Manchester is ordered to make
widespread reforms after some staff were
filmed allegedly abusing patients
Beijing is now essentially in lockdown
as China reports its highest number of
daily covert infections ever
well good morning from the World Cup and
Qatar where England and Wales are coming
under increasing pressure to defy FIFA
and that one love armband ban after
Germany's silent protest yesterday
[Music]
morning everybody a fresh wave of
strikes has begun which many believe
will be the start of a winter of
discontent across the UK workers are
demanding High wages to keep up with the
soaring cost of living schools will be
closed across Scotland and a postal
strike will hit businesses hard just
weeks before Christmas but while the
government says it can't pay wages that
match inflation more unions are
balloting their members on Industrial
action and more strikes are in the
pipeline
so the Royal Mail their workers begin
two days of strikes today set to cause
some significant disruption to Black
Friday shopping hundreds of thousands of
pupils will be out of school as the
first teachers strike in almost 40 years
takes place in Scotland today three days
of strikes begin at 150 universities
right around the country expected to
impact on 750 000 students Mick Lynch
from the rmt will meet the transport
secretary Mark Harper following the
Union's announcement of further strike
action over Christmas and nurses are
among some of the NHS professions due to
strike in the coming months
let's get more should we either is
standing by for us this morning hi Ivor
um tell us where you are what's
happening
yeah it's getting to the point now okay
uh good morning by the way getting to
the point now where it's hard to keep up
with all the strikes Now isn't it so
this picket line is outside the delivery
office in North London as Royal Mail
workers
um begin a 48-hour strike time to
coincide as you say with the Black
Friday discount shopping season a
massive um massive period for online
retailers and delivery companies too now
this picket line is just one of
thousands across the country 115
000 raw male workers will walk out in
this long-running dispute overpay jobs
and conditions Royal mails say the
company needs to modernize but the
unions say their plans for a seven day
delivery service will turn the company
into a gig economy style uh parcel
Courier and so they've rejected what
Royal Mail say is their best and final
offer of a pay increase of up to nine
percent they say over 18 months and what
this means is widespread disruption to
the service at a time when online
retailers need it most the retail sector
is worrying that this these strikes
could triple the Black Friday shopping
season with more stripes planned after
next week's cyber monday deals too and
more strikes planned throughout December
including on Christmas Eve so this is
just one set of strikes but as you say
out strikes elsewhere today today by
teachers lecturers and more strikes
planned on the rail network to either
side of Christmas now later this morning
there will be a crunch meeting between
the rail Union boss Mick Lynch the
figurehead of those rail strikes and the
transport secretary Mark Harper will
have to wait and see what comes from
that now we're not at the point yet of
coordinated strike action but with all
the strikes going on it certainly feels
like we're edging closer and closer
towards that okay thank you
uh breaking news from the energy
regulator off gem on the new price cap
our business correspondent with Godfrey
is here with us hi tell us more yeah so
off gem it's the energy regulator it
caps the amount that energy companies
can charge customers for each unit of
electricity and gas the announcement
that it made today would normally mean
that your typical household based on
typical usage would see that energy
bills from January go up to 4 279 pounds
a year wow that's a terrifying number
but before I cause any alarm this
doesn't mean that people's bills will be
going up by that March or too that much
and that's because the government has
stepped in you may have heard of the
energy price guarantee but it's
effectively promised to cap People's
Energy bills that typical household that
we like talking about at 2 500 pounds up
until April and then from April it will
cap it at 3 000 pounds for another year
so you may be thinking well if I don't
have to pay it it doesn't affect me but
someone does have to pick up the bill
and that that figure that has to pick up
the bill it's the government so the
difference between the government's cap
at 2500 and off gems cap is being born
the cost is being born effectively by
the taxpayer and it's a huge amount of
money we don't know exactly how much
this intervention is going to cost
because we don't know what wholesale
Energy prices are but some forecasters
are saying that this could cost us in
the region of about 38 billion pounds
over 18 months was that factored in well
it's Diamond it was factored in yes it
was factored in but it's changing all
the time because wholesale prices are
changing constantly and to put that in
context furlough cost us a hundred and
billion 100 billion pounds over 18
months so it's a massive massive
intervention and uh critically it's
untargeted so whether you're rich or
poor everyone's getting support and this
is something economists have also warned
about because they fear that by giving
people this cash it could actually fuel
inflation at a time when we only
inflation is running at a 41 year high
and that could force the bank of England
to put up interest rates so the costs of
all of this will indirectly be borne by
all of us okay Bruno thanks very much
indeed thanks a lot sorry about the
Manchester United co-owner avram Glaser
he's tell us guy news that now is the
right time for the club to explore
strategic Alternatives of investment
including a potential sale in his first
public interview since Tuesday's
official announcement Mr Glazer also
praised the Star Striker Cristiano
Ronaldo who's left the club after
controversial remarks in which he said
he had no respect for the manager our
U.S correspondent James Matthews caught
up with avrum Glazer in Florida and sent
this report
it's a long way from Manchester but West
Palm Beach and Florida is where the odds
shortened on a sale of the Reds
on streets populated by the super rich
we tracked down one of the money man
minded to sell
avram Glazer club owner Mr Glazer Hawaii
is now the right time to sell Manchester
United hi well as we announced yesterday
the board went through a process and
it's decided it's going to look at
different strategic Alternatives and
that's what we're doing so United fans
say that you should have sold the club
years ago
well once again we've gone through a
process we're going to look at all
different all strategic Alternatives and
we'll see where that leads us so I
appreciate you talking to me tonight and
I'm going to wish everyone a Happy
Thanksgiving Cristiano Ronaldo says that
you don't care about the club and
thousands of United fans agree with him
why why should they be wrong well I'll
tell you about Cristiano Ronaldo he's a
great Management Center player I
appreciate everything he's done for the
club and I wish him the best luck in the
future thanks very much why did he have
to leave the club why did he have to
leave the club before he began World Cup
Duty Cristiano Ronaldo had left
Manchester United with a part in short
at the Glazer family saying they didn't
care about the football side of the club
many in the support have long been vocal
in their disdain of the Glazer family's
ownership
Manchester United fans have made their
feelings clear here in Florida the
supporters trust has written to the
Glazer family
urging them to sell and sell quickly
saying the last 17 years have been
characterized by debt and decline on the
field and of it the fans trust told them
they would carefully scrutinize any new
owner it is the supporters demand to be
heard when the money talks James
Matthews Sky News in West Palm Beach in
Florida
well as England prepares for the next
game against the USA we look at what has
turned the USA from four guys to Serious
contenders for many years America's men
dismissed football but I've embraced it
now they are in the world's top 16
serial qualifiers for the World Cup in a
way countries with a longer tradition of
the sport are not let's talk about it in
more detail Alistair standing by for us
playing the USA tomorrow
England playing in the USA tomorrow yes
in the second round match let's not
forget Wales are playing Iran as well
same group they are up against uh the
team that England beat 6-2 on the
opening round uh and it's an important
match for Wales having drawn against the
United States if they do beat Iran
they'll put themselves in a very good
position to qualify out of that group
England if they beat the United States
will automatically qualify into the next
round so there's a lot riding on the
matches tomorrow we'll hear from both
teams later on this evening here in
Qatar on the eve of those second round
matches Harry Kane who was an injury
concerned because he took a knock on his
ankle during that Opening match and he
went for a scan yesterday uh all
indications though are that he will be
fit and ready for that match uh of
course if Gareth Southgate decides to
pick him and why wouldn't he but I think
he can be buoyed by the fact they
managed to knock six past Iran without
Harry Kane in scoring a single one of
them because they have relied on the
Tottenham Striker so much in the past
but now it looks like there are goals
coming from all areas of the pitch for
England so very positive for them I
think Wales will take a heart as well
from their Opening match against the
United States a pretty poor first off
from them but they managed to rally and
come back for that draw but the scandals
continue and there will be pressure on
both England and Wales to make some sort
of statement during their matches
yesterday they have been banned from
wearing the one love armband as were the
Netherlands Belgium Switzerland and
Germany but as we saw yesterday in
Germany's match uh before they uh kicked
off the pre-match photograph saw German
players cover their mouths in a sign
that they are being silenced and that
was their form of protest against FIFA
will England Wales do the same we'll
have to wait and see I'm sure that will
be one of the questions at the press
conference later and still to come on
the program before you uh there's more
disruption on the horizon as postal
workers today begin a 48-hour walkout
over paying conditions speaking to a
union leader about what this means for
this Black Friday weekend
also joined by the leveling up secretary
Michael Gove
and then at 7 45 joined by the smps Neil
gray as pro-independence protests
breakout across Scotland
also making news for you today a site
that scanned thousands of victims out of
millions of pounds has been taken down
in the UK's biggest ever anti-fraud
operation police here were part of a
global operation to stop a phone number
spoofing site involving fraudsters
ringing up people and posing as Bank
staff so far 120 arrests have been made
they've tricked individuals by calling
them by spoofing A bank's number so the
victim believes that they are having a
call from their Bank they're then
accessing their Bank their details and
they're with inside their bank accounts
and they're tricking the victims into
providing a one-time password and then
they're clearing out their bank accounts
of all their money
the home office will present their case
in the Shimona begum hearing today in
which she's contesting the government's
decision to remove her British
citizenship in 2019. begum's lawyers
have argued the decision was unlawful as
the school girl may have been a victim
of trafficking when she left for Syria
in 2015. in court Beckham's mother said
her world fell apart when her daughter
left seven years ago
data published today of every GP
practice in England will show how long
and how frequently people have to wait
to be seen it's hope the move will
improve transparency around performance
and allow patients to make more informed
choices about the practice they choose
transport secretary Mark Harper has told
Sky News the rules for carrying liquids
in hand luggage are being kept under
review followers reports that security
restrictions for liquids and laptops in
hand luggage could be removed within two
years due to the roll out of 3D scanners
at airports since 2006 passengers taking
liquids on a flight have been limited to
a hundred mil bottles which they must
put in clear plastic bags
they are trailing I think those scanners
at Heathrow at the moment came through
Shannon Airport quite recently flew
through didn't have to say anything out
my bag no laptops or anything they've
also got them I think at schipple
airport really make a difference to
those queues remember just yesterday we
were talking to you about the longest
cues for security here in the UK are at
Leeds Bradford Airport best is London
City talking about that in more detail
um in the nine o'clock hour here on Sky
News meantime China facing a record
number of new covid cases with residents
in beijing's most populous District
urged to stay home let's get more should
we Helena is standing by for us this
morning this is going from bad to worse
isn't it for the people of China
yeah it really is key I think it's a
highly symbolic very very significant
moment for this country daily covered
infections exceeding 31 000 uh yesterday
and that is the highest number that this
country has ever reported at any stage
of the entire pandemic of course it's
worth saying that right back at the
beginning in 2020 it's not like any
country in the world had any blanket
testing regime so you know there could
have been more cases then but it is
nonetheless very very significant and it
means that cities across this country
are resorting to what we would consider
in Europe to be reasonably old-fashioned
measures lockdown things get enclosures
I just want to show you around a bit so
okay this is part of the busiest Central
business district in Beijing the cues
for this covert testing Booth are
normally absolutely huge and they've
been tiny today and that's because
people are being asked to stay at home
businesses are all pretty much shot no
restaurants no bars they can do takeaway
but that's it certainly no shops uh
people being asked to work from home
people are allowed to kind of go out to
take a walk to to buy some food or
whatnot but that is about it this city
is essentially in lockdown as are a
number of other cities across China and
it's just worth also saying okay that in
the city of zhenjo that's the other
place that people have been focusing on
this morning Junjo is where one of
Apple's biggest iPhone factories is
there's a huge plant there and there has
been a covert outbreak there over the
last couple of weeks and for two
consecutive nights now workers uh their
anger at the conditions there has really
spilled over there was violent clashes
with police last night for the second
night in a row just worth emphasizing
how incredibly unusual these types of
scenes are in China there is a sense
that people are frustrated in that
factory plant that they're not being
able to leave there's also a sense that
people have complained they haven't had
enough food there's fear that different
people with the virus are mixing with
those who don't have it there's a lot
going on and some of it's very difficult
to decipher because a lot of it's been
very heavily censored and it's very
difficult to access people there but a
sense I think that this policy in
different parts of this country is
streaming straining at the seams and
remember Chinese people are sitting at
home watching the World Cup and many
asking why the rest of the world can
gather in big groups without masks live
their lives normally while this country
very much feels it is still under the
heavy weight of zero covert we're saying
there are people here who support the
policy they think it's keeping them safe
but there will be big big challenges for
the government in the coming weeks as
these cases continue to rise how to keep
them in check and how to keep people
happy as well okay thanks very much
indeed Helena thank you keeping an eye
our close eye on that story for you also
keep an eye on what's happening with
industrial action up and down the
country postal workers have begun a
48-hour walkout over paying conditions
impacting this Black Friday shopping
weekend let's speak to Dave Ward should
we General Secretary of the CWU
communication Workers Union of course hi
Dave good to see you thanks for joining
us on the program this morning I'm
guessing you've timed this strike for
now to have Maximum Impact with Black
Friday
well I think Kay we've got to be honest
here that postal workers who are only 18
months ago were being held as key
workers for keeping the country
connected during the pandemic and now
facing the most brutal attack on jobs
that we've seen in this country for
decades what's going on and I really do
wish that people could look into what's
actually taking place in not what the
company is saying the truth is that this
company is axing thousands upon
thousands of jobs
it's at the same time replacing decent
postal workers by refusing to lay off 11
000 agency workers and recruit in new
self-employed drivers and new workers on
almost 20 percent less terms and
conditions this is outrageous behavior
and the company itself is also
destroying Royal Mail as we know it they
have no intention of continuing Royal
Mail one of the most iconic British
companies that are there is a round they
are destroying it they want to turn it
into just another parcel Courier and I'm
going to say to you today the people who
are running this company have got so
much to answer for the the levels of
harassment and intimidation and threats
that are going on in workplaces every
day would be unacceptable in in any
business and yet it's the leaders of the
company who are doing this to Ordinary
Decent postal workers and we're not
going to put up with us we cannot accept
what they're doing we don't want to be
on strike we want to reach an agreement
we want to serve the communities that
our members have been doing for years
and years and I just wish that the
government would really look at this I
think this is getting bigger now than
just a dispute about our members jobs
terms and conditions no company should
be allowed to leave a group of workers
in a service so popular as Royal Mail in
the way that they're doing it
okay what sort of threats have your
members been subjected to
well I suggest that you speak to postal
I'm speaking to you Dave you made the
allegation tell me what they are yeah
yeah yeah no okay I'm making the
allegation because it threats about
micromanaging people every day telling
them when they've got to work when they
can't work threatening them if they
bring Mal back because there's quality
of service failures that they'll be
sacked so they're trying to put pressure
on people to work beyond the time
they're being paid uh just speak to
postal workers they'll they'll say I've
seen women postal workers recently
resigning
um because saying that their mental
health is being affected by the leader
of this company who spends all of his
time on his workplace social media
platform almost at war with his own
workers there's no CEO in the in the
world that would behaving that way and
be allowed to get away with it and this
is such a serious dispute now you know
we're calling on the public to
understand what we want is real
modernization we want modernization
that's going to work for customers for
the future of the business and for our
members this is not what we're facing
this is an asset stripping plan it's a
leveling down payment and I don't know
what this country is coming to if this
is the way that that workers are going
to continue to be treated let me take
you back to my initial question if I may
please um Dave and that was about you've
timed this for Maximum Impact on Black
Friday haven't you and I can understand
why you've done that but what would you
say to those businesses who are trying
to get themselves back on their feet and
they're absolutely relying on things
like Black Friday in order for their
business to recover after the pandemic
I would say to them that we've got no
choice and what they should be doing is
posing those questions to the company
who were only out last week facing the
market and this is what this is about as
well they face the market and say the
business is in a sound place got a great
asset Base Great balance sheet and then
they come to us and say they're running
out of cash and we will be bankrupt in
three months somebody needs to look into
this this is not the fault of postal
workers people know postal workers want
to want to be serving the public serving
businesses but we cannot accept this
level of attack so you know there's no
other alternative for us at this point
in time okay
um the company is saying you've been
offered nine percent over 18 months and
there is no more offer on the table and
there isn't going to be 99 over 18
months sounds like a pretty good deal to
some I'm guessing
okay if there was an offer on the table
with nine percent over 18 months that
was back dated uh so that our members
got the full value of that and it was
linked to real modernization we wouldn't
be standing here today we would have
accepted that offer that's not what's on
the table and I come back to the point
about the level of job losses that are
going on I mean ask anybody why would
you sack postal workers in the numbers
that they're sacking at the moment and
at the same time retain 11
000 agency workers and Recruit new
workers self-employed workers and
workers on 20 less pay terms and
condition is somebody going to suggest
to us that we should accept that would
any worker in the country accept that
would would the government accept that
is that how you grow the economy these
things have got to be challenged now on
a higher level than just us fighting for
our members jobs and decent postal
workers fighting for their jobs the
government need to intervene in this I
don't think it's any kind coincidence
Kate the the chairman of Royal Mail is
also the guy who wrote the report on the
railways uh the same people and we
genuinely feel that there's a
coordinated approach here to attacking
workers who are just standing up for for
their jobs their pay their terms and
conditions we want modernization we've
agreed that the thing that Romel really
wanted was one parcel Network we've
actually agreed that during the week we
said to him we're willing to agree that
but they just relentlessly they want to
start people three hours later what
company that delivers Parcels letters
and packets says to its Workforce we're
going to start you three three hours
later and we're gonna we're gonna grow
this business it's not about that uh
Dave we're out of time but thanks can I
say something to you tomorrow we're on
strike we're on strike tomorrow okay I
know get get Simon Thompson in the
studio with me and we'll debate this
yeah
okay that's what your colleagues think
of it um I can certainly say that we've
got one of the bosses of uh Royal Mail
on Ian King live uh from 10 o'clock so
do stay tuned for more on that
thanks a lot Dave no
um also we've got uh the leveling up
secretary who of course is Michael goeth
he is joining us in just a few moments
here on the program as well uh meantime
this will make you smile hundreds of
Paddington bears and teddies left in
tribute to her majesty the queen are
being re-homed by the royal family and
bernardo's uh the queen Camilla uh will
today attend a special teddy bear picnic
at bernardo's Nursery to personally
deliver the Paddington Bears to Children
supported by the charity
I was in Peru recently and went to the
cloud forest where Paddington was
supposed to have come from yes I did um
hello again everybody uh the minister
with us very shortly indeed before that
our top stories this morning Christmas
Chaos excuse me a winter wave of
industrial action as workers across all
sectors of the economy walk out
Manchester United's co-owner avram
Blazer has told Sky News the club is
exploring strategic Alternatives of
investment after suggestions the club
will be put up for sale
and the England Wales football teams are
under pressure to protest excuse me
against the one love armband ban
following Germany's silent statement
yesterday
an NHS Mental Health Trust has been
served with warning notices to improve
after inspectors found not enough staff
were caring for patients the Care
Quality commission carried out
inspections at the greater Manchester
Mental Health Trust following an expose
which found a toxic culture of
humiliation verbal abuse and bullying at
the edenfield center in prestwich here's
Katarina with more
Helen has asked us to hide her identity
to protect her child earlier this year
her adult daughter had a psychotic
breakdown and tried to kill herself
Helen says it was a fight to get help
from her local service the greater
Manchester's mental health NHS trust she
needed help desperately but it took a
long time to get that help I just felt
there was nothing no help I did ask for
help but they were busy they didn't have
enough time it was always me ringing the
police ringing the ambulance driving
around to find her if she'd gone missing
it felt like on one hand she needs the
services but in the other you have to
ask what do Mental Health Services
actually provide
Helen's daughter is now on a hospital
Ward under the trust's care but she's
worried after allegations of abuse in
some of the Trust Services you are
scared about what happens there what
happened when she was in rehab and she
used to ring me and say it's mad here
and I don't know really you don't know
when you're not on those Wards with them
the person that you really care about
what are they experiencing Services as
earlier this year an undercover BBC
report showed the trust staff on award
at this facility near Manchester
bullying humiliating and mocking
patients today the trust was placed
under an enforcement order after an
investigation by the Department of
Health and Social cares Care Quality
commission deemed that the trust as a
whole was not safe a spokesperson for
the trust said we accept the findings of
the cqc's recent inspections at our
trust and are committed to making the
changes and improvements that our
service users deserve work is already
underway in order to build better and
more sustainable services but this
mental health campaigner who works with
families says they've been raising
safety concerns with the trust for more
than two and a half years and we're told
that nothing was wrong we knew it wasn't
good about the care and this is
something I think that the review
process needs to look at how come that
Senior Management have been so insulated
from the realities of what's happening
on the ground NHS England has already
intervened putting the trust this week
under a new management strategy there
will be also an independent review and a
deadline to make improvements and make
services safe Catherine evertotsi Sky
News in Manchester
pleased to say that the leveling up and
housing secretary Michael Gove is with
us now good morning thanks for joining
us on the program this morning moldy
houses
um you I believe are suggesting that
organizations like those in Rochdale
should get their money cut because of
moldy houses how does that help people
who need to rely on these associations
well housing associations should be
looking after their tenants first and
we're not giving money to people who are
not even looking after their existing
properties to build new properties
they've got to make sure that they look
after their tenants
um it would be I think wrong of us to
give public money to an organization
that is failing until it gets its uh its
own act together but how does cutting
money to them help them do that well
this is money that is there for them to
get uh building new homes if you can't
even run the homes properly that you are
currently responsible for then you
certainly can't be building new homes
and this money will be used across the
country in order to build new homes but
Rochdale by a white housing they're not
getting it because they failed as as
you've reported Kate in this horrific
case and they've got to make sure that
they are spending the money they've got
effectively at the moment before we give
them any more but if you give them more
they can build better housing stock well
this is about new homes and existing
homes and the critical thing is they
have the money they need they've got the
resources they need in order to deal
with the problems that are currently
preoccupying me and so many others it is
not right that taxpayers money should go
to allow an organization to expand
particularly an organization that was
paying its chief executive north of 150
000 pounds they should not be getting
extra cash until they use the money they
already have to improve housing and I'm
saying to all housing associations that
their responsibility is to deal with the
damp the mold and some of the other
problems that have been identified by
campaigners that are meaning that there
are uh you know uh thousands of tenants
who are living in homes which are not
fit for human habitation
um where do you stand on the argument
about building 300 000 new homes a year
because it seems to be splitting the
party at the moment and thus the
government um we all know that we need
to build new homes I think there's a
consensus about how we build new homes
there's a conversation
um about how we make sure that the
tanning system works better and some of
the uh concerns that have been raised to
concerns that only have two
um we need to make sure that when we
build new homes that they're beautiful
and high quality we also need to make
sure that we Safeguard um Greenfield
sites wherever possible and prioritize
our housing on Brownfield sites that's
both good for cities helping them to
regenerate it's good for the environment
too Greenfield sites wherever possible
does that mean that you would uh
Brownfield sites wherever possible sorry
you said Greenfield starts you said that
wherever possible you won't build on
greenfields exactly so yes but you you
are not ruling out building on some
Greenfield sites if necessary uh well
the green belt is protected but the
priority always is Brownfield first and
then last year
um the the balance has been tilted in
favor of of Brownfield sites in a more
profound way than ever before but there
is there is more to do and as I say it's
both good for cities we've seen great
cities like Manchester revive and grow
with more people living in the Town
Center as a result of regeneration we
are trying to do that elsewhere with the
help of local government and the help of
an organization called homes England
that's got millions of pounds to help to
do that
um and that is not only good for those
cities and good for leveling up as we
encourage the great cities in the
Midlands and the north to grow it also
helps to relieve the pressure on uh
green fields that is good for the
environment as I say you're a very busy
man I heard you in the House of Commons
earlier in the week um saying that you
feel sorry for younger people than you
do potentially for pensioners that's not
going to go down very well with the
Bedrock of conservative supporters does
it um well my mum and dad are pensioners
and I'm naturally on their side but one
of the points that I was making is we
have to recognize that over the course
of in the last few years for a variety
of reasons partly the rest of you have
covered young people are having a a
challenging time and I want to make sure
that we extend opportunity to the Next
Generation and that means both building
the homes that they need but also making
sure that we get our economy onto an
even Keel um after the the turbulence of
covid and the war in Ukraine and provide
them with the opportunities that they
need in order to succeed in the future
talk to me about Michelle moan what do
you remember about the PPE contract with
Michelle moon when she approached you
how did that conversation go well during
the pandemic there were lots of people
who were approaching us with offers of
PPE I referred all of them to the
appropriate Civil Service channels in
order to make sure that the uh PPE that
we were being offered was of sufficient
quality and could be sourced in time it
was a procurement process which every
offer went through in order to assess
she did approach you with your personal
email no well lots of people approach to
be um personal email yeah there were
lots of people who approached me whether
it was through email text
um or uh or uh uh in the precincts of
the House of Commons or wherever to uh
say that they could help us because as
you'll remember at the time
um not just in the United Kingdom
um but across Europe uh we needed to
Source PPE quickly
um and uh anyone who approached me I
said thank you very much and made sure
that uh their uh their efforts to help
were referred to the appropriate
officially run independent channel to
assess whether or not the PPE that they
were offering um was value for money so
what do you remember about the personal
email that she sent you
um uh that she was one of uh a huge
number of people who were approaching
the government at the time uh who were
so you don't remember specifically her
approaching you uh I remember lots of
people approaching me you remember her
specifically approaching you I do
remember the thing about um baroness
moan is that uh uh uh you know as you
know she's a strong personality
um but there were lots and lots of other
people who approached me as well anyone
who approached me I thanked and then
made sure that they went through the
appropriate process so that anyone his
claim was assessed not by me as an
individual but by an independent process
okay but what do you remember about her
personal approach to you what do you
remember about that email uh that I
remember that she was uh Keen to ensure
that uh PPE which the government needed
at that time was provided
so you can't remember exactly what she
said uh well lots of people approached
me at the time I'm asking about her
specifically yeah I know and I'm saying
that lots of people approached me so uh
uh what I can recall is that she said
that the uh there was an organization
that she believed would be able to
provide PPE for the government and I
said to her as I said to everyone thank
you very much that's very kind we do
need PPE but I'm not the person who can
make that decision as to whether or not
this contract should be awarded okay but
you did forward on that uh that contact
and yeah as I did with lots of people
because
specifically about her how do you feel
about the fact that millions of pounds
was wasted because of that introduction
well uh I don't know uh uh the detail of
what happened once that uh bid was
referred because it was nothing to do
not my question Minister my question is
how do you feel about the fact that
millions of pounds was subsequently
wasted because of an introduction that
you uh were first approached and then
made to other members of government
wasted in what way well because uh
apparently it was quite a lot of it
wasn't fit for purpose well again that I
regret the fact that any PPE that was
purchased was not fit for purpose but my
recollection is that the overwhelming
majority of PPE that we did uh by was
fit for purpose at that time we're
talking about this specific case and it
was a 200 million pound contract some
suggestions that she made 19 million
pounds personally you know that's at
alleged I don't have the facts that can
confirm that or otherwise but what we
can say is a lot of that PPE uh was
subsequently not fit for purpose and it
was in introduction through you how do
you feel about that in hindsight
um well I regret the fact that any PPE
that we sourced was not fit for purpose
but the job that I was doing at the time
was to make sure that at the time when
uh we were facing a terrible pandemic
that anyone who wanted to help anyone
who was making an offer of PPE was
referred to the right channel
um I would have hoped that you or I if
someone said I can provide PPE that we
would have said great the thing to do is
to go to this official government
process to go through this procurement
gateway to have the quality of uh the
contract that you're seeking to secure
assess I understand but I'm asking how
sorry you are now that actually all that
money was wasted because of an
introduction that was made by you
um I
the first thing I was going to say is
that
um I introduced lots of people so of
course I regret the fact that there was
any that was wasted but but what you're
trying to imply is that um it was I'm
just asking how you feel about it I mean
I would be mortified if it had been me
um uh because because there's a lot of
money that's been wasted yes of course
it is and of course the one of the
things is that none of us want that
money to be wasted but the the uh the
problems that we had with PPE at the
time meant that we were anxious to
secure contracts from everyone the fact
that some contracts meant that some of
the material that was uh procured was
not upstairs a decision that was made in
haste
um well everyone was making that
decision it's correct everyone's making
that decision on the basis of what
individual organizations put forward and
what the independent process decided I
did not decide
to award that contract
you didn't you're right I'm talking
about energy
are you having my water yes
I wonder how you're saving energy at
home because the Chancellor's telling us
that we need to save 15 on our energy
bills what are you going to do uh well
at home I try to you as much as possible
make sure that uh uh I turn down the
thermostat uh that I uh limit my energy
use but again I'm conscious that uh as a
minister I'm in a relatively comfortable
position compared to uh to to many
others so I think the right thing to do
is to make sure that we Safeguard people
with the energy price guarantee and we
also provide people with routes to get
the advice that they want on how to
minimize their energy usage we know that
you're a very healthy man we often see
you out uh running when you do need to
go to the doctor do you use a private GP
uh I uh wherever possible always use the
NHS but I have on occasion used private
medicine
um we know that the Prime Minister does
that as well is that what do you think
that says about the optics for people
when they have to wait a fortnight for
their GP and the boss who is in charge
of of that system can spend 250 quid and
just I think the most important thing is
making sure that all of us do what we
can in order to ensure that the NHS gets
the resources that it needs
so you support him using a private GP
when he wants to uh I think everybody
that's got enough money should use a
private GP to take pressure off the
system uh no I wouldn't give anyone else
any advice about their own health care
choices
no question before I let you go these
pesky 100 ml bottles at the airports
apparently that's going to be scrapped
with these new scanners I don't know if
you've heard that or not
um how relieved are you about that
um well whenever I fly I always take a
minimum level of cosmetic and other
ambulent uh uh with me so I don't think
it will make much of a difference to me
but for those people whom it will make
fine more convenient I'm delighted it's
great to see you um take the water with
you we'll meet you thank you thank you
very much indeed as always it's great to
see you quick look at the papers for you
a referendum Indie bin that's how the
Metro headlines the Supreme Court ruling
that a second
independence vote in Scotland can't be
held without permission from Westminster
the eye says that the PM is facing a
battle with their own MPS who are
demanding he comes up with a clear
agenda to take the party forward
Tamara's here hi tomorrow that was
interesting wasn't it about Michelle
moan and also about the fact that he
does use a private GP that's right yes
story in the guardian today alleging
that baroness moan
um who was enabled by the conservatives
she um received a secret 29 million
pounds they claim from a PPE uh contract
with the company that she claimed to
have nothing to do with Michael Gove
concedes that the initial contact was
made with him that she contacted him to
say that she wanted to supply PPE she's
been questioned quite a lot over the
last year or so about why it wasn't
declared and the guardian now have
documents suggesting the money was moved
to an offshore trust that she and her
family benefited from so it's more about
this VIP Lane which ministers have
repeatedly defended saying we were
acting at speed we had to procure this
PPE during the covid crisis but sounds
like a lot of people may have enriched
themselves on the back of some of these
big contracts so I heard from him on
that and of course his big announcement
today is about social housing he's going
I understand to Rochdale later today to
speak to some of the people who were
involved in the decisions around our
ishak's family who contacted them
repeatedly saying we've got mold in our
house come and deal with it and clearly
those concerns were not acted on so he
says he's going to go there and that
he's going to restrict that Housing
Association from having any more money
to build new affordable homes until the
regulator is completed its work although
there are questions about whether
giving them less money is actually the
answer to this problem he says it's new
money to build new houses and he's not
going to give them the money and that's
right over the coming five years yes
until immediately they were expecting a
million pounds over five years and they
can't have any to build new homes until
this is sorted out but I think sort of
Labor and some in the housing sector say
that the re obviously there was a
cultural problem with them not acting on
concerns but perhaps the reason for a
lot of social housing being dilapidated
is lack of money so
um I think there'll be questions about
whether more enforcement is actually the
answer okay for now thank you
um the Scottish national party says it
will use the next general election to
revive their campaign for Independence
after the Supreme Court ruled another
referendum cannot be held without
westminster's approval joining us now is
the smp's minister for culture Europe
and international Affairs that's Neil
gray hello to you Mr Gray thanks for
joining us on the program hi good
morning good morning that's the end of
that then isn't it
no it's not it's the the YES Movement
the independence movement in Scotland
now becomes the Democracy movement in
Scotland because it's incumbent it's not
a a a a small question it's not a small
issue to expect uh governments to
respect democracy you know the people of
Scotland elected a parliament in the
Scottish Parliament last year with a
record number of pro-independent
supporting msps the last time that a
majority of pro-independence msps was
elected was in 2011 when the then Prime
Minister David Cameron respected that
outcome and granted the section of 30
order which uh granted the temporary
power to the Scottish Parliament to
legislate to hold an independence
referendum it's incumbent now on Russia
sunac to answer the question about
whether or not the UK is indeed a
voluntary Nation if it is what's the
route by which people in Scotland and
elsewhere in the UK can determine their
future and get around the table with
Nicholas sturgeon and agree either the
temporary or the permanent transfer of
powers that allows people in Scotland to
determine their future
um that's as maybe but the SNP given
what the Supreme Court said and ruled
yesterday is now a busted flush because
you cannot have another Independence
referendum without the say so of
Westminster and they're not going to let
you
well I think that makes the case for
Independence better than any of us in
the SMP possibly could because at the UK
that people voted for in 2014 no longer
exists
um it's no longer a voluntary Union of
Nations we're held against our will and
the UK that was voted for in 2014 no
longer exists because we were ripped out
of the European Union against our well
whom we're told that the only way to
stay in the European Union would be to
vote no so I think it it is incumbent
now on people to respect democracy this
is not a small question this is
fundamental to our democracy and the way
that we are viewed around the world and
I do expect at Rishi sunak to have to
answer that question around the
voluntary Union and around whether or
not it's how it's got people in Scotland
and elsewhere in the UK are able to
decide upon their Futures you know at
the moment as it stands and an English
political party or or people in England
wouldn't just need to elect a majority
of MPS in the UK parliament in order to
extricate themselves from the union now
at this point in time the SNP of course
has a majority of Scottish seats in the
House of Commons and a record majority
um exists in the Scottish parliament of
pro-independence msps what more is
required for people in Scotland to be
able to determine their future
Democratic uh what more is required is
that Westminster must allow you to do
that and they're not going to
which again makes the point makes the
case for Independence I hear you but
it's not going to make any difference
because Westminster has to allow you to
the the court the Supreme Court the
highest court in the land said this is
what has to happen and we know that the
prime minister is not going to do that
yep and so we will need to make sure
that um our democracy movement in
Scotland which is now the
pro-independence movement uh gets on the
streets we campaign we can continue to
convince people of the merits of
Independence and we use the next
Democratic event to ensure that people
in Scotland can have their say
yeah you're talking about a general
election
um we also know that that cannot be used
as a referendum uh for Independence
nobody says that it cannot
um the the perhaps people would prefer
that was not the route and we certainly
think that the best way of people
determine their future is the gold
standard of the 2014 uh referendum where
there was an agreement reached between
the two governments and a referendum was
held that allowed people to have their
say of course since then circumstances
have changed the UK that people voted
for in 2014 no longer longer exists in
that we've been ripped out of the
European Union against our will but if
the plan B route whereby we allow people
to express their view in an election
event such as the next general election
uh then that is what we have to do we
would prefer a referendum process that's
a clearer
um more International recognized route
um but if we have to go through the
process of the next election event then
so be it and we'll set out our plans for
how we can do that in the coming months
okay so there is a general election and
the SNP wins a finite number of seats um
it's still not a referendum you would
still have to say as a result of this we
feel that we can leave um and have our
own independence and whoever the Prime
Minister uh at Westminster is at the
time will say no you can't then
and then you'll have Nations around the
world looking on a Gog at the UK and
that's Antigone what they'll say is that
you said in 2014 that it was a once in a
lifetime uh vote and the people of
Scotland good people of Scotland said
you know what we want to stay part of
the Union
and we respect the result of the 2014
referendum but circumstances have
changed profoundly since then for you
know just one reason that I've set out
which is that we're taking against out
of the European Union
why I say that it was once in a lifetime
vote
it was a once in a lifetime opportunity
democracy does not stand still it's not
what you said a event you know we've had
three prime ministers this year we've
had four chancellors we've had you know
we have general elections uh regularly
the people are allowed to change their
minds in a democracy and it can't be
that Scotland is unique in that we're
told we cannot be allowed to change our
minds and we cannot have be allowed to
we cannot have a a respect for the
Democratic expression that we have
um you know and I think it's going to be
incumbent on Russia sunak now that you
know this is some unionists may well be
gleeful today but actually this uh
result of the Supreme Court decision
poses fundamental questions about the
United Kingdom so you don't respect the
Supreme Court
we of course with respect to the Supreme
Court I've said that very clearly of
course I should respect the outcome of
this supreme court and the judges that
have taken that decision what I'm saying
is what that judgment does is pose
fundamental questions for the UK as we
know it and the way that we see it and
that won't be um fundamental questions
just for people in Scotland to look at
but for people outside of Scotland as
well as to whether or not that truly is
a voluntary Union and if it is how we
can how a constituent part of Scotland
being one can extricate itself okay
could you talk to you Mr Greg I'm sorry
we are out of time but it's good to talk
to you thank you very much indeed thanks
a lot thank you